l'ultima cosa da decidere
definitivamente se lei si trovi in una
commedia o in una tragedia per citare
italo calvino il senso ultima cui
rimandano tutti i racconti a due facce
la continuità della vita
l'inevitabilità della morte
tragedia lei muore commedia se a casa
noi non abbiamo come il personaggio di
questo film è un narratore esterno che
decide quello che accadrà nelle nostre
vite e di certo non apparteniamo a un
determinato stile letterario
però mi piace pensare che c'è una
qualche similitudine tra quello che
accade il personaggio di vero come la
finzione e quello che succede
internamente a noi ovvero la nostra voce
interiore che continuamente giudica le
nostre azioni
influenzando le nostre scelte e di
conseguenza influenzando la nostra
felicità io vorrei chiederle di fare
un'esperienza insieme a me vorrei
chiedervi di girarvi e presentarli tra
voi e avete 5 secondi per farlo quindi
prego giratevi e presentatevi
in uno studio realizzato dalla brigham
young university in utah è stato
dimostrato che l'isolamento e la
solitudine hanno delle conseguenze più
nocive per la salute di quanto ce
l'abbiano versità
isolamento e solitudine predicono una
morte prematura sotto i 65 anni quindi
non pensiate che perché siete giovani
siete immuni a tali rischi noi intanto
ci siamo appena presentati e forse con
un po di fortuna abbiamo appena
aumentato la nostra aspettativa di vita
ma voi vi chiederete cosa c'entra
l'isolamento e cosa c'entra la
solitudine con l'ottimismo che è quello
di cui io sono venuta oggi a parlarvi
ebbene questi due sono sintomi molto
noti della depressione e la depressione
non è altro che la forma più cronica di
pessimismo più patologica ovvero la
totale assenza di ottimismo e se voi
pensate che la depressione non è un
argomento sul quale puntare l'attenzione
io vi invito a guardare le statistiche
che per il 2020 e almeno negli stati
uniti predicono la depressione come
principale causa di morte dopo le
malattie cardiovascolari
parliamo di ottimismo
cos'è il secondo voi l'ottimismo è una
forma di vita è uno stile di pensiero
un'emozione
qualcuno si è già a posto questa domanda
fortunatamente la fatto nell'ambito
empirico e scientifico uno dei primi è
stato il professor lionel tiger che nel
1979 ha scritto un libro ottimismo
andrologia nel quale ha approcciato
all'ottimismo dal punto di vista
antropologico
secondo il professor tiger l'ottimismo è
stata una forma di trattamento biologico
che ha sviluppato l'uomo primitivo per
riuscire a sopravvivere
sostanzialmente l'uomo tende ad
abbandonare tutte le attività che sono
troppo rischiose invece l'uomo primitivo
ha sempre trovato la forza per uscire
delle caverne è procurarsi da mangiare
una delle ipotesi riguarda il rilascio
di endorfine e le sue proprietà
benefiche dal punto di vista euforico e
anche analgesico diciamo che forse
l'uomo delle caverne è stato uno dei
primi amanti degli sport estremi
ma studi più recenti e quasi va il 1990
hanno introdotto e l'ottimismo come
qualità presa come frutto
dell'esperienza il professore martin
seligman dell'università di pennsylvania
ha introdotto per la prima volta il
concetto dello stile esplicativo l'hotel
esplicativo non è altro che le
motivazioni che noi diamo continuamente
a tutto ciò che ci accade che sia di
carattere positivo o che siano delle
avversità questo stile esplicativo può
essere ottimista può essere pessimista
temporaneo o permanente ea seconda di
qual è il nostro stile esplicativo
influenziamo continuamente il nostro
successo in tutti gli ambiti dal lavoro
alla salute alla politica la religione è
anche nelle situazioni di massa come e
lo sport parliamo per un attimo della
salute lo stile esplicativo ottimista ha
un'influenza sulla salute che è notevole
ed è in tre modi in primis le persone
ottimiste anno le difese immunitarie più
attive e perciò rimane rimangono in
miglior salute in più le persone
ottimiste godono di un auto e stima più
elevata e questo li porta a prendersi
cura di sé e anche godono del supporto
sociale migliore perché tendono a
sviluppare dei rapporti di amicizia di
amore e più duraturi e questo è stato
provato che ha un'influenza notevole
sulla salute e cosa si può dire sul
mondo del lavoro
gli ottimisti e quasi ti amo il
professor sneijder dell'università di
cannes da ri kansas hanno una componente
proattiva che indispensabile nel
successo lavorativo e si parla della
pianificazione gli ottimisti tendono a
cercare
se tangibili nel mondo circondante per
poter supportare la propria posizione
ottimista davanti alla vita e in più
sono persone più perseveranti e voi lo
sapete meglio di me quando si inizia un
progetto di intraprendenti sia un'idea
l'entusiasmo è fondamentale all'inizio
ma è la persona che diventerà cruciale
nel tempo quindi a questo punto ci
possiamo chiedere c'è una relazione
diretta tra l'ottimismo e la felicità
sono le persone più ottimiste ad essere
di conseguenza più felici perché
sviluppano di rapporti interpersonali
migliori hanno una migliore salute più
successo al lavoro o il contrario
persone che per le circostanze sono già
più felici e diventano ottimisti e lo
rimangono nel tempo sulla felicità si sa
che un bel 50 per cento dipende dalla
nostra condizione genetica equa e sfido
tutti possiamo fare ben poco oltre che
accettarci ma un altro 40 e 10 per cento
dipende dalle nostre circostanze e dai
nostri pensieri la domanda è riusciamo
ad influenzare questa seconda metà la
risposta ce l'ha già data facebook nel
facebook ha realizzato uno studio su
700mila utenti e l'ha fatto senza il
loro consenso ma qui non siamo venuti a
fare polemica e in questo studio a
segmentato i contenuti esplicati
all'interno del newsfeed degli utenti in
maniera positiva o negativa si voleva
provare se questa segmentazione poteva
influenzare il loro stato d'animo e la
risposta è stata esattamente quella e
gli utenti sottoposti a stimoli negativi
hanno iniziato alla loro volta a postare
contenuti del tono negativo e viceversa
davanti a questi fatti ovvero che
l'ottimismo sia così indispensabile per
lo sviluppo per il successo per la
felicità è che lo si riesca ad indurre e
ad influenzare io insieme un gruppo di
ragazzi abbiamo avuto un sogno e nel
2014 abbiamo iniziato a pensare di
creare uno spazio virtuale segmentato di
notizie positive notizie che potevano
arrivare sia reazione che da contenuti
originali creati dagli stessi utenti e
così è nato social social è un social
network segmentato in maniera positiva
che funziona con la geolocalizzazione
che ci permette in tempo reale vedere
quale l'ottimismo a livello globale e
che funziona in maniera fruibile però
non volevamo fermarsi soltanto alla
segmentazione
volevamo che questo fosse uno spazio
dove si potessero misurare i
comportamenti virtuali in maniera tale
da generare delle statistiche come una
certa valenza dal punto di vista socio
economico e che fossero di carattere
ottimista
ma avevamo una sfida davanti non è
facile popolare o sul nuovo social
network
lo sapete bene e in più e volevamo
combattere l'isolamento che come abbiamo
sfiorato all'inizio è una componente
indispensabile per chiudere il cerchio
così abbiamo ideato un'applicazione
questa applicazione è ancora in fase di
sviluppo è stata presentata in anteprima
a las vegas in occasione del collision e
anche accolta positivamente da una delle
agenzie delle nazioni unite qualche
giorno fa a new york questo questa
applicazione uno spazio virtuale che in
tempo reale nel raggio di pochi
chilometri permette alle persone di
interagire attorno alla risoluzione dei
problemi quindi sostanzialmente io posso
postare una richiesta d'aiuto e far
diventare qualcuno che non conosco il
mio eroe spontaneo perché questa persona
può aiutarmi in tempo reale questo
progetto come tanti altri sono solo una
delle mille forme che pochi acquisire
l'ottimismo se presso alla vostra della
ricerca e dell'innovazione ed è da parte
mia e da parte del mio team
un invito a tutti voi a non
sottovalutare l'ottimismo nelle vostre
scelte personali e professionali
noi intanto all'inizio di questo spirito
si siano presentati alcuni di voi magari
avete una memoria migliore della mia vi
ricorderete nel nome della persona che
avete conosciuto altri magari solo del
loro volto ma l'importante è che quella
persona non è più un estraneo e i suoi
problemi non sono più così lontani ne
così a strati è questa credetemi è un
occasione per renderci utili per
diventare magari gli eroi degli altri e
soprattutto è una ragione per rimanere
ottimisti sul futuro
grazie mille